wow
sweet setup what do you make here don't
worry about it oh cool cool coco cool
cool
i'm just gonna add it
oh
so uh so we can add things now
yeah why not right i mean we got the
time and we got the ink everything but
the cajon sang what did i just say and
that is under charles
back to the window get back in the
window
so
how was your night of work i'm not
asking about your personal life i don't
care about you personally i mean i'm
neutral i mean who are you floundering
is worse than silence oh cool go go go
go go go go no doubt no doubt no doubt
yeah it's elevator's slow huh great rule
number three let's not have sex right
away
cool cool
no doubt no doubt no doubt no doubt good
rule no sex good rule hey sharon how are
you doing vaginally what don't ask her
that okay jake all you have to do is
keep her comfortable i'm on my way okay
sounds good and do you want to just meet
us at the hospital no
okay got it got it cool cool cool no
hospital i am picking up what you're
screaming down you may get painful
greater-like swelling in your neck and
often extreme testicular discomfort
okay
no doubt the one dumb wedding thing i've
always wanted was a bachelorette party
ah so cool cool cool all the pressure's
on that one event cool cool very cool no
problem i don't need your id federal
database is down anyway wink wink huh so
how do you like your ammo by the box
above the bucket cool cool cool cool our
country is broken what if he isn't
taking his medicine you could mix it in
with his food sorry you can deal with
your sick dog later boyle well actually
that was about my son nikolaj he's got
allergies i think we may have to go with
the nasal douche ah nasal douche
very gross i'm gonna catch this last
fugitive win the bet and then we're
gonna live together for the rest of our
relationship just you and me and towel
makes three cool cool cool cool cool hey
peralta how's it going man pretty good
thanks for asking ooh cool cool so how's
it going um still pretty good okay okay
this is bad this is really bad but just
remember
we are not going to jail we didn't do it
we're innocent guilty on all charges
oh
guilty
very cool
cool
cool cool cool
cool so does this mean that i'm part of
the crew
nobody can touch you now wow guess all
it took was the ramen tip actually you
got to do one more thing for me to close
the deal absolutely no problem i
actually have a great idea for a ramen
dessert you make it with jell-o mix i
need you to kill a guard
okay great
cool cool cool beef babies out for blood
so
ah those are our stolen shoes but who's
miss bk sneaks her name is jenny
mcfadden she moves her merch out of the
back of a bodega on willoughby cool cool
cool wait if boomer's not doing it who's
running the task force detective brett
booth from 6-3
cool cool cool uh-oh that was your word
cuckoo cool oh
stop my mom
stop for my
we were mom bad i can't believe we
thought we were gonna make it so what
are you even up to man well i'm still
trying to get the music thing started oh
cool cool never give up
so
so
so
rose is bye yes jake i remember go
stay man great thanks
[Music]
hi there who are you and why are you
following me i'm not following you
i come for charles boyle
hey hey hey hands where we can see him
chill out bro it's not gun it's just uh
it's a toy no [ __ ] pretty place it's
gift
for nikolas nikolaj how do you know
charles's son my name is guintas from
latvia
i am nikolaj's birth father
oh
nikolaj's birth father who i never hoped
to meet very cool cucu
hey by the way we don't have to pretend
we're undercover here the hospital staff
knows we're cops oh i wasn't setting up
cover was i well just the kids thing
saying that we were gonna start trying
soon oh i'm sorry i didn't mean right
away i just meant in the near future oh
okay
cool this side of the room lunch is on
me and we're getting something better
than pizza sushi
are you trying to outdo me no no
just trying to raise morale
cool cool cool morale morale morale
okay that's it
debbie fogle you are under arrest what
oh my god are you not really dirty no
and i'll be taking that gun
okay so the women's gym and the cocaine
have given debbie's superpowers
cool cool
coco coco don't say cool instead say
indeed oh indeed indeed indeed indeed
indeed
that's weird look raymond a
yellow-crusted warbler yes that's the
right level of excitement for such a
bird you captured the essence of kevin
you've done it correction i've
accomplished it indeed indeed indeed
indeed
it's growing on me
you